good evening a major concert taking over
allegiant stadium tonight so the big
question is will there be parking
headaches thanks for joining us at six
i'm denise feldes and i'm christian
casadas guns and roses is playing at a
legion in about an hour and if you're
going there are things you should know
orco mana is live at allegiant with a
look at the parking and what you're not
allowed to bring into the venue orco
well this is a big deal as you guys know
guns n roses is a popular rock band and
fans are flocking here to legion stadium
to see them perform the doors opened at
five and the parking lots around the
venue opened at uh four o'clock and you
can see here we have a bunch of fans
already arriving here you can see them
trying to walk through uh the sidewalks
here and the streets and we have some
cones and traffic personnel here to
direct them and so far we haven't seen
any crowd or traffic issues in the
parking lots or in the areas around the
legion and the hope is that things will
stay that way but you'll remember there
were issues during the garth brooks
concert and the gold cup final now here
are some parking reminders for you on
site at allegiant there are lots a
through j and there are additional lots
of property where you can park you can
also park at certain mgm properties such
as mandalay bay and the luxor and for
those looking to avoid parking the
rideshare drop off zone is at the front
half of la and on dean martin drive a
short walking distance to the stadium
and here's a look at allegion's bag
policy approved bags include 12 by 6 by
12 clear backpacks clear fanny packs a
one gallon plastic freezer bag and small
clutches but you will not be able to
bring in regular backpacks purses or
oversized tote bags as well as these
other items on your screen legion also
telling us that the nfl policies are
what they use for bags and you won't be
able to bring your bags like this one so
you'll be asked to leave and bring them
to your car or you can use allegiance
bag check system but you'll have to pay
about twenty dollars again guns and
roses playing here to legion stadium in
just under an hour it starts at seven
o'clock reporting live at allegiant
tonight orca mana 8 news now